(audience applauds)
- Welcome to
the Kelly Clarkson Show, everybody.
Give it up for my man, y'all.
(audience applauds)
Chelsea with her balls at the end.
I like that.
I like, you look ready for a music video.
That was Madonna's 1990 classic, "Vogue".
If I needed to tell you that, what?
(audience laughs)
Obviously,
everybody knows that.
But we just did it to be kind, I guess.
This is so cool, but when she kicked off
her "Celebration" tour
in London this year,
her youngest daughter,
Astaire, showed up on stage
during this photo.
And Astaire went all out with
a Vogue dance performance
that made her family so proud,
as you can see from the photo.
♪ Jingle bells jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
(audience cheers)
- Happy holidays, everyone.
♪ Oh what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one horse open sleigh hey ♪
♪ Jingle bells jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one horse open sleigh ♪
(audience cheers)
Happy holidays!
- That's enough!
- What?
- I was like,
what the hell?
- Look it.
- Wait, what are you doing?
Sterling K Brown, everybody.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you, everybody.
- What are you doing here?
- Listen, I was in town
to promote my new movie,
"American Fiction".
- Oh my gosh.
- Out in New York and LA December 15th.
- I got to find out where to go, okay.
- But I come bearing gifts.
- Oh, okay!
- Take a look.
- Wait, okay.
- Open that top right there.
- Yes!
(audience applauds)
You remembered.
- I remembered.
I remembered.
- You remembered.
- How do I like to eat these?
- So, I don't know if you guys don't know,
Kelly enjoys Doritos
without the whole Doritos.
- Nope.
- She just likes to lick
the dust off the Dorito
and then throw it away.
So, yeah.
- Yeah.
It's an addiction.
- You could, you gonna try
the whole chip this time?
Or maybe-
- I'm gonna do it right now.
- Are you really?
(audience cheers)
You gonna do it?
- Wait, wait, one, one, one.
You should try it.
- Okay, give me one.
- Try it, just the dust.
Just the dust.
- Give me one.
Just the dust?
- Uh huh, uh huh.
- It's not gonna look-
(audience laughs)
- It's so good.
It's so good.
- It isn't bad.
- And then,
you toss the cookie.
- You toss?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I'm just saying,
it's, I don't know if I have
some kind of salt thing.
I don't know what happened.
- It's good though.
- I really like-
Wait, wait, you're here.
- Yes.
- You're promoting, I love
this building so much.
Random people stop by.
I love you so much.
(audience applauds)
What are you promoting?
What are you doing right now?
- I'm promoting a movie
called "American Fiction".
- Yeah.
- Right?
Starring Jeffrey Wright, Erika Alexander,
Tracy Alice Ross, myself,
Issa Rae, et cetera.
- Wow!
- It opens
December 15th in New York
and LA, and then it rolls out
nationwide at the beginning of 2024.
Please come out and support.
(audience applauds)
- Wait, those are
amazing actors.
- They are.
- What is it about?
What is it about?
- It is about a writer, who's frustrated.
Black writer, who's getting
frustrated, because he wants
to write different things, but
the only thing that America
seems to wanna see has to do
with people in dire straights
that look like me.
So he writes something
as a spoof about people
in dire straights that
look like, as a joke,
and it becomes like his
best selling novel ever.
- Of course.
- It's a comedy.
- Check it out, please.
- It's kind of a comedy, but kind of not.
- It's kind of all of that.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was like, well kinda really
sad and we need progress.
- Kelly Clarkson, you look good.
- Thank you!
- Can I just say,
Kelly Clarkson look good.
- I love that you said that.
And you brought a Christmas sweater.
- You can't come empty handed.
That's what my momma told me.
- I love that I got you to do it.
I got you to try it.
(Sterling laughs)
- I licked it.
- You're like, this is gross.
- I licked the chip.
No, it was tasty.
- It's so good.
- It's really good.
- Man, I could do that whole bag.
- Come on, Kelly Clarkson.
- Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so "American Fiction", right?
- "American Fiction."
- "American Fiction"
December-
- December 15th,
- 15th.
- New York and LA.
- Everybody!
(audience cheers)
I love you for stopping by.
I'll see you next time.
- So good to see you.
- And you sing a hell of a "Jingle Bells".
- You stop.
- Thank you.
- Bye, everybody!
("Jingle Bells")
- Wait, wait, thank you, Brenda.
That was-
Well, that was awesome. (laughs)
I love this building so much.
You have no idea what will happen.
I love that he brought me Doritos.
(audience laughs)
Look, I'm really weird
but I don't know if
there's like a deficiency,
I don't know what's
happenin', but just try it.
It's so good.
Just both sides, you don't need the chip.
It's like less caloric
intake is all I'm sayin'.
But your tongue does feel like a cat's
by the time you're done.
You know that weird, yeah.
Anyway, no one's kissing me, I don't care.
(audience laughs)
Let's bring out-
Or more like, I ain't kissin' anybody.
Anyway-
(audience cheers)
I'm just kidding.
I'm so weird, okay.